we want you to participate in the World
Economic Forum on the Middle East and
North Africa at the meeting held in
Marrakech we will conduct four sessions
around key topics concerning the region
and we'd like your feedback on some of
these questions what top initiatives can
the US and the Muslim world introduced
to change the dynamics of the
relationship what are the top strategic
drivers of deeper engagement of leading
Asian economies with North Africa what
are the top regional initiatives that
can foster systemic resilience these are
the evolving global risks what top
innovations would retell the examination
systems to drive education reform we
want you to comment on the proposals
made by world leading experts to our
questions or to add new ones submit your
feedback in text or with a video no
longer than two minutes to youtube.com
forward slash Davos you could also vote
for your favorite submissions your
feedback will be incorporated in the
Proceedings of the World Economic Forum
on the middle east and north africa with
some of the most powerful and
influential people in the world go to
youtube.com forward slash Davos to join
the conversation